check out the story from Newsweek fact
check does project Veritas video show
Pfizer is mutating covet hold on there a
little minute Newsweek why are you fact
checking a claim that's not been made
this is the interesting about how the
media manipulates public perception
project Veritas released a story that
says Pfizer director says thing they did
not say thing was happening they said
hey look we filmed a guy who said
they're exploring mutin kovid that he
thinks the virus came from the lab Etc
or or intimated that it did
so the media does is does project
Veritas video show Pfizer is mutating
coven
when no one made that claim right now
they can come out and say false it
doesn't here's the crazy thing about it
though
we'll jump straight uh straight down to
the bottom actually it leans slightly
towards true it says unverified so it's
not misleading it's not false and it's
not satire it's just unverified which
puts their needle leaning towards true
okay that's kind of crazy because James
did not say that they that Pfizer as a
company was doing this thing now a bunch
of people that complain about the fact
check because the fact check does just
needlessly disparage project Veritas and
falsely frame the question at hand but
when even Newsweek anything Newsweek
isn't the worst but when even they try
to falsely frame this and still end up
with well I can't say it's not true yeah
it's kind of interesting where we're at
these days yeah I don't know and they're
just trying to throw so much like white
noise I think at it to avoid the obvious
question I mean everything that guy says
is very compelling especially when you
verify his CV like this guy actually is
working on these things and the obvious
question is what is he talking about but
then they have to throw this well you
know did he did they really say they
were doing gain a function just debunked
in that yeah I guess the crazy thing is
the media is not even they're completely
ignoring it yeah I mean I I should say
it's crazy in the context of Newsweek
trying to do a fact check yep it's crazy
that ever that this is completely being
ignored when the video I think it got in
like eight hours 10 million views
probably more because I shared it other
people re-hosted it things like that but
I but I'm pretty sure 10 million views
in this video in a day
it's wild I mean I I think that I think
the consensus here is probably that he
was not actually lying that he is
telling the truth because even if you're
even if you were thinking I'm going to
tell this person stories that are not
true to impress them why would you tell
them the stuff that the people you just
said you are afraid are coming to find
you why would you tell them the stuff
that they're looking at here that's why
I was saying like when he's in the video
being like you're not one of those
secret conservatives recording me right
it's like he's starting he's starting to
think wait a minute did I just spill the
beans on this one yeah but ultimately I
guess here's my question we'll make it
political like what do we do about it so
let's let this guy said this thing okay
he did it's a fact he said it James
O'Keefe has done his due diligence and
shown this guy his list that is having
this job so uh what do we get like other
other should the Republicans subpoena
this guy I would think so yeah they're
doing the uh the covet investing
education they're launching that what do
we get out of it do you think anything
will come of it well hopefully we get
some sunlight and we get to actually see
once and for all maybe not everything we
want to see but we get some very basic
questions asked I mean I I think this
just goes into the file of all the other
evidence we have I mean everything
that's happening right now in the
medical community died suddenly all that
the questions that people have I would
add this to that long list and that this
guy should be subpoenaed you know he
should be he should be questioned or the
folks that work for him his supervisor I
mean this just gives us a starting point
I think it's interesting that he is so
comfortable with this information that
you know first second third date he's
talking about it right like that's
unusual everyone has a first day
anecdote that they you know bring out to
like show your personality or whatever
and this is his right so that means that
he's in an environment where they're
openly talking about this comfortably
right like this can't be the only person
he can't have only told a project
Veritas person about this like who else
and that means that this is something
that they because what struck me about
the first video is him saying like oh
yeah it could be bad for America but
it's good for us and then in this video
he's like talking about himself how
could he ever trust anything like it
it's only self-centered motivation yeah
do you think
the Republican Congress is actually
going to do legitimate investigations
into all of these issues I mean it's not
just the pandemic stuff you got the
hunter Biden stuff we we talked about
this before they before they narrowly
won but we're not entirely confident I
mean we as in the people on the show
that uh Kevin McCarthy is actually going
to give us real investigations so far so
good I mean I uh I I think what the
direction they're heading right now
they're putting the right people on
those committees I mean MTG is on the
covid committee I mean how that that's
pretty awesome we've got Jim Jordan uh
Dan bishop and a couple other Fighters
that are on the the government
accountability of the modern day Church
committee
um going after the intelligence
Community that's when you have the
administrative state so we've got the
right people lined up now a big question
is what can they do they can issue
subpoenas unfortunately since the budget
got approved all these different
agencies they have their money so these
agencies can do what they just did with
Jim Jordan he issued some subpoenas and
they said the doj said we'd love to we'd
love to help however this stuff's all in
our investigation so we can't help you
so Congress is a little bit Limited in
saying that hey if you guys don't show
up and participate we are going to
withhold some of your funding that's not
going to be available until next year
but I think right now the direction
things are heading I think we will start
getting some some answers at least my
biggest fear is is not about answers is
it's that we'll get some kind of answers
but there will be nothing that's done
like we could find out terrible things
that Pfizer is doing awful things but
because the executive branch is is
Democrat and it's Joe Biden I don't I
don't see him actually making a move but
this is what that's exactly why I asked
it James O'Keefe does this sting
operation gets a pretty damning quote
from someone high up at Pfizer being a
consultant or otherwise maybe he's lying
sure this warrants in my opinion
investigation absolutely
but it's not even about the executive
branch it's like so we have this this
panel of course there's people like
Marjorie Taylor green are they gonna
itch of the subpoenas are they actually
going to get documents are they actually
going to make people come in and testify
even beyond the executive branch but I
think your Point's better that we can
maybe assume Marjorie Taylor Green's
definitely do something yeah but then
what the doj does nothing yeah the only
thing Congress has the is the
sergeant-at-arms other than that it's
like they can't they can't do anything
to to make anything happen unless the
exact unless you are evil like Chef yeah
well I mean even to be fair he didn't
even get to
another good thing is that we got shift
kicked off the Intel committee Chief Dan
swallow well that dude is pretty epic
evil man yeah absolutely and he's held
accountable I mean he he released
private phone records of a single member
of Congress Devin Nunes and he released
the private phone records of a U.S a
private U.S citizen yeah John Solomon
and a journalist
he he said in February of 2018 that they
had evidence Trump colluded with Russia
but it just wasn't publicly available
this guy was lying yeah the whole time
that's scary that's like one of the
number one ways you can abuse your
security clearance I mean I had a
security clearance the entire time I was
in the military I worked in the CIA for
a little bit but for him to lie and say
I have this access to classified
information it's really bad I can't tell
you what it is you just have to trust me
we need to start ruining people's lives
like that anybody else would be
absolutely annihilated out of the
intelligence Community can you can you
talk about your time at the CIA sure
limits like what what did you do yeah I
was a paramilitary operations officer so
case officer who is has a special
operations background who goes into this
paramilitary temperature he's a CIA guy
that gets into gun fights there you go
yeah yeah so the core mission of the CIA
is to go out and to recruit human
sources a lot of places that we need to
do that are very dangerous places and so
they'll hire guys out of Special
Operations but so you work directly with
the CIA you weren't like a contract or
anything no yeah I was a full I was a
full-on GS employee what's what what's
your general opinion considering what
we've seen with the doj with the
intelligence Community with a lot of
corruption what's your what's your
assessment oh it's rotten to the core I
mean the CIA the FBI doj like the
problem is we've had these bureaucrats
that have been running things at the mid
to senior levels the pentagon's the same
way I spent 20 years in the military
your average person who enlists in the
military or becomes an officer in the
military they you know they want to
they're just you know like I was they
want to go serve their country same
thing in the intelligence Community
however there is this administrative
class that endures every single
Administration that we really never saw
rear its ugly head in all of our
lifetimes obviously Kennedy and all that
but really until Trump came in so I came
in in 98 under Clinton served all the
way through and like when Obama was
elected most of us I was a Green Bay at
the time you know we lean a little bit
right not all of us but we weren't happy
that Obama won but we took an oath to
support and defend the Constitution
Obama was the boss none of us questioned
it you know fast forward eight years
when Trump gets elected and that's not
who the administrative State the mid the
managerial class that's not who they
want and it was a night and day
difference like they basically said that
they were not going to adhere to Trump's
orders and they follow through that like
how did they Implement that uh they
implemented that mostly by just slow
roll I mean especially this is basically
the long story of how I got into
politics my late wife was also in the
military she was killed fighting Isis in
Syria one month after Trump gave the
order to pull our troops out because
Trump ran on hey I'm going to end these
endless Wars we need to go fight and
Destroy Isis but once we destroy Isis
we're not staying in Syria there was a
huge concerted effort there still is
within the administrative State the dod
to keep us in Syria and do like another
great regime change War because those
always work out so well and Trump wasn't
having any of it he gave the order to
pull the troops out Mattis resigns Brett
mcgurk over at State resigns and Trump's
orders the commander-in-chief the people
that the American people chose his
orders were completely and totally
disregarded and the month later my wife
was killed over there so that's and so
I've seen that time and time again and
with trump it went everywhere from like
the benign Slow Roll public resignation
all the way to everything we've seen
with Russia gate the tools of the
intelligence Community being used
against a candidate and a political
campaign at the time all the way to
while the guys in in government you know
I mean I could go on for I could go on
for hours about about all that but yeah
I mean I think the Trump Administration
just really because they weren't
expecting him to come in and they
weren't expecting him to push back so
hard we really got a snapshot of what's
going on below the surface there that's
something that I think is is one of the
most valuable things about the Trump
presidency
um as much as there are people out there
that are going to go ahead and and
say that Trump was you know a foreign
agent or in bed with foreign agents and
stuff it really did show that the
bureaucracy really is the whole it's the
uniparty one there's one agenda that the
government has and the whether it be
Republican or a Democrat the differences
are are marginal you know you're talking
about a two or three degree shift in
policy mostly cosmetic yeah and then you
get someone in like Trump that
regardless of what you think of him it
seems like the guy really wanted to do
the things that he said and everybody
was flipping out because when does a
politician try to do the things that
they said they're going to do like that
hasn't happened in decades or whatever
so I think that it was a really good
thing that that at the very least Trump
being in office and seeing that the
bureaucracy the the entrenched
bureaucracy or the Deep State whatever
you want to call it they literally are
running the show and will do everything
they can to
throw a monkey wrench and even the
presidents so yeah what do you say to
people who will just say you're you're a
Fed why should I trust you yeah I mean
that's uh I understand I get that
actually quite a bit
um yeah
I mean I tell people my background was
my job in the CIA is you know
counterterrorism but if we're going to
take down the administrative State we
need people from the inside who
understands exactly how the sausage is
made where the where the secrets are
kept and those types of things because I
think a lot of times we get when
Congress calls these intelligence
officials Department of Defense folks to
the carpet and says hey explain things
to us they say well I can't it's
classified that's sources and methods
and if you have people that have worked
in that space before you can really
start pushing back I'll say two things
the first is
to that point about needing people from
the inside to come out and explain
what's going on I mean this is what
project Veritas does yeah they get
whistleblowers often sometimes it's a
sting sometimes it's a whistleblower
right so how many people work for
project veterans Veritas right now who
are literally the people at Big Tech
working on the censorship who said this
is bad I can't do this and then went to
Veritas said let's change it not to not
to uh dissimilar you working for the ca
coming out saying hey this is bad we
need to change it yeah however I will
also add the old saying once CIA always
CIA right so so sure I think this is why
a lot of people are well this in in the
chat they're all like fedcast
The Spook is here I feel like it must be
different you're describing like being
Green Beret taking this out to office
like you say like oh yeah I didn't want
to bomb in but like I took an oath
whereas like you have this other class
that like feels like when they lose they
get to manipulate the system right you
know what I mean like I could see maybe
you are a Fed but at the same time you
know I could see that there is a
division even within that and
to me that speaks to a lot of the
dissatisfaction with military like the
uh the lack of military recruiting that
we have right now I mean you if you guys
can't turn around and say the next guy
coming up hey like there are some
challenges but it was worth it then how
are we going to keep that system rolling
maybe we shouldn't I don't know how
we're gonna keep our country I mean
that's a big thing like when we can't
recruit for the military like I'm
against all the escalations and all that
but we need to have a military if people
aren't willing I mean that's a huge
issue people aren't willing to join the
military you know the weirdest thing to
me is this um
this can it's it's like it's like a
demand for conspiracy it's a demand Ron
DeSantis starts giving people everything
they want he opposes critical race
theory he opposes the gender ideology he
opens up the country he starts
implementing these policies then we
start hearing from just some people
they're like it's too good to be true
he's he's deep State he's got bad people
around him and I'm just like if you
can't
vote for exactly what you want you've
lost already yeah exactly so it's like
the best thing you can do is
support what
is good and what you need and want and
hope for the best but like politicians
lie I mean what can you expect the thing
that sucks is Mo is like most people
feel the same way and so that's why you
have the the you know the the
uniparty you get Democrats and
Republicans and people are like well I
don't really like the Democrats but I
really hate the Republicans so I'm going
to vote for the Democrats and then you
have people that are like well I really
hate the Democrats I don't like the
Republicans much but I'm going to vote
for the Republicans no one gets a
perfect candidate and I think that a lot
of the problem is people look at our
government as if it's as if it should be
a top-down government and they stop they
don't realize or don't think about the
fact that the people that are gonna have
the most effect on their daily lives or
their local politicians their Congress
people if you write your congressperson
you may get a response if you write your
Senator you ain't getting a response you
write the president you ain't getting a
response but you go to your city council
you start going to school I've been
going to a lot of school board meetings
in this process I've had to be a
candidate and I mean that's school board
meetings and engaging with your Sheriff
I mean that right there that's the stuff
that actually affects people's everyday
lives it's a little bit different we had
harsh covid lockdown so we had the
overstaff of the federal government and
our governor as well but yeah that's
that's but it's still the local
politicians that are going to battle the
federal government on your behalf right
yeah and you still need them you legally
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time